ich glaub es geht schon wieder los
[Musik]
ach leute alle jahre wieder würde ich an
dieser stelle sagen alle jahre wieder
kommt das christuskind auf die erde
nieder wo wir menschen sind und bringt
uns einen emp adventskalender als erstes
haben sie einen selbstgemachten gehabt
der ist so sehr gut bei mir angekommen
ihr habt einfach müll gemacht ihr zieht
eure kunden mit diesem kreis kalender ab
und letztes jahr haben sie einen
wellness und beauty adventskalender
herausgebracht der war auch ganz okay
das ist ein beschissenes 24 türchen
denen sie dachten sie sich kommen
vanessa liebt alkohol den kann sie nicht
schlecht bewerten und das finden wir
jetzt heraus denn dieser adventskalender
ich mag ihn aus es ist nach 10 uhr fragt
nicht was auf dem bild auf meinem handy
war so was haben wir uns dieses jahr
gebracht ist aber ein ding das ist ein
teil über eis und lampen ich packe man
kurz nicht folie aus bis es dann am
sportfeld das wird doch alles so schön
sie erstmal aus dieses mal hat das
komplette marketing team mitgearbeitet
dieses jahr sind sie all in gegangen
haben einen kalender für 119 euro haus
gebracht dieses jahr ist der kooperation
mit nun scheint das ist ein alkohol
hersteller ich bin der meinung dass sie
nur likör machen also ich hatte mal nun
scheinen nach hause geschickt bekommen
und es war haselnuss likör irgendwas mit
barry ja sowas und nun scheint das wiesn
ist noch schreiben ja und die kühe
halten sowohl
mit geschmack ansonsten schreibt gerne
die definition in die kommentare das
denn likör so ausmacht haben das
leckerli schönes ding optisch gefällt er
mir sehr gut ich bin einfach gespannt
wie ein flitzebogen ich habe mir auch
irgendwo shop gläser vorbereite die sind
auf dem weg verloren gegangen schott
gläser vorbereitung heute wird getrunken
trinken feiern tanzen 119 euro was sagen
wir dazu sagen das hat seinen preis eine
alkohol ist nicht günstig aber wenn man
sehen ich auch schon mal ich kann ein
paar sachen nachrechnen und ob es sich
dann am ende lohnt das ist hier
natürlich das wenigste geld wir fangen
jetzt einfach anders wir lassen uns
überraschen türchen nummer eins ich weiß
nicht warum aber ich finde es einfach
lustig kirche nummer eins befinden
befinden sich zwei pralinen
trophy macadamia wie körperlich likör
praline ok alles klar wir gewinne sehen
die aus ihr habt ihr mann seine frau
nina denn hier wartet
zunächst mal bin ich der größte fan von
alkohol in süßigkeiten also auch in
kuchen oder halten kugeln oder sowas
aber
das ist ein angenehmer alkoholgeschmack
also sitzt nicht so overwhelming wir
machen wir weiter wir lassen uns
überraschen natürlich nummer zwei jetzt
kommt das was ich von nun schon kenne
und zwar von shine hoffman
& shine produziert sogar in berlin
schnaps kein honig 25 prozent alkohol
nicht ohne
also ein likör was nach karamell
schmeckt den wir müssen jetzt auch die
nun scheinen seite überhaupt gehen um
die preise nun scheinbar die nina und
hier kann man bestimmt gestellt
da sind die kleinen ein liter kostet 43
euro 100 milliliter kostet also vier
euro 30 das sind 50 milliliter bei eur
15 ich bin gut in mathe ich bin werde
ich werde nicht jeden likör probieren
ich werde ein paar liköre probieren aber
ich mache jetzt nicht jedes kleine
flächen auf titel nummer drei 40 sehr
erleichtern
[Applaus]
von sonne scheint das egal wo man etwas
damit beschriften kann und ein gutschein
für zehn euro ich schreib mal die 10
euro an der seite auf weil so einen 10
euro gutschein ja okay das bedeutet aber
dass ich ja eh geld auf der seite lassen
werde und vielleicht auch hier das
andere sondern ende machen wir gewinnen
bnp fans ist er schon cool ich habe
niemals auf die seite irgendwie 4
wieder einkehr macadamia die
weihnachtszeit ist es cool so karamell
macadamia sind schon gute geschmäcker
ich glaube dieses jahr gibt es nicht so
viel zu meckern ich habe das im gefühl
das ist ein ganz stabiler
adventskalender wird hier nummer fünf
ich bekomme
[Musik]
flashbacks
crispin wie hätten diese dinger noch mal
ansteckbuttons frage was soll denn da
jetzt noch eine kerze kommt dann liebe
ich diesen kalender haben was schreiben
wir für diesen aufwand sich sein okay
alles klar 20 sind so jetzt haben wir
jetzt haben wir nikolaus was erwartet
uns an nikolaus leider nur ein kleines
wieder ein neuer geschmack auch sehr
weihnachtlich nun schein bratapfel bald
probleme ja es wird eigentlich wert ein
probieren man könnte daraus auch seine
küsten sbu ole ole ole und dann halt
nicht so weihnachtlichen geschmäcker mit
zimt und bratapfel und kann man sich so
dar ausschenken türchen nummer 7 na klar
das braucht man für die so einen deckel
der große aus dieser kostet 92 ich würde
dann mal aufschreiben 1 euro 80 obwohl
die technik ist ja dann die gleiche der
deckel ist ich schreibe 250 auch denk
dran
119 euro ist übersteigt sogar die 70
euro vom ersten damals hat natürlich
hier nochmal auch rathenows ja den kenne
ich auch der hat glaube ich so ein
haselnuss geschmack oder so und schmeckt
wirklich auch lecker am feldrand war
schwer diesen wunsch ein likör in ein
cocktail einzupacken weil ich nicht so
viele nennt man das ja jetzt trinkt man
ja meistens fruchtige cocktails und mit
karamell und so habe ich so selbst ein
cocktail gemacht wird damit immer nicht
ganz genau weiß was ich machen soll aber
nun scheint falls mal komplett sie
ballern sponsern möchten gerne also je
nachdem wir dieses video hier ausfällt
dann können wir leben
jetzt kommt meine lieblingszahl ich höre
jetzt kommt was gutes ja ein großes
thürig hier ein großes küchen kann nur
bedeuten jetzt wird geil ich habe angst
ja es cool das sind okay
[Musik]
hergestellt in italien und da ist das
oben drauf ich find's cool also das ist
universell einsetzbar größe 41 46 aber
es wird meine fußfetischisten jetzt
kommt mit eure zeit und doch nicht
leider auch der bands geländes im weg es
tut mir so leid
[Musik]
war ein voller erfolg ist nur jetzt
müssen wir herausfinden wie viel kosten
die hier socken 41 bis 46 lang ich würde
sagen irgendwas zwischen fünf und zehn
euro weil man muss ja die stückzahl
bedenken gehe ich würde sagen stückzahl
machen wir fünf euro es ist nie schön
warm an den füßen und das schreit nach
türchen normal sehen endlich jetzt noch
mal zehn haben wir wieder den macadamia
likörs wiederholt sich meine leute ok
man kann darf man so lecker sein soll
dann probieren wir den
[Applaus]
an den verschluss hier
draußen wir sind ein kleines jubiläum
aber schon niedlich geschaut mal
[Musik]
anprobiert das ist eine probier größe
damit bin ich auch interessant
echt nicht schlecht wir sind gar nicht
bis nach macadamia schmeckt also tut ja
aber der geschmack von macadamia ist so
ganz einfach so ein angenehmer was ich
überhaupt nicht wie haselnuss ich find's
gut dass man den kalender auf jeden fall
mindestens zwei jahre wieder verwenden
kann wenn ich sogar drei weil die
kartons sind sehr stabil also das ist
hier aus alles aus einem festen
pappkarton hat sie was positiv gefunden
türchen nummer
etwa wieder karten uns ich glaube jetzt
gehen den leuten die sorten aus mir auch
schon mal zwei euro 15
jetzt werden wir beschenkt bereit
ich finde mache mir da sind so eine
sache hat die schon hundertmal zum
geburtstag geschenkt bekommen und auch
verschenken aber benutzen tut man sie
wirklich im seltensten fall ein winter
mit so einem liqueur stelle ich mir das
immer wieder lustig vor man dann so
eislaufen ist oder keine ahnung im
schnee spielt und dann kommt man so sein
ding raus und trägt mit seinen freunden
so ein schuss aber ansonsten hat so ein
flachmann halt einfach so ein kind frei
neben der frau dürfte nicht sehen aber
der sehr schön habe noch nicht so
einstellen gesehen mit so einem tollen
das echtes leder
das ist keine da machen sie keinen
schriftzug drauf und müssen wir einen
preis von flachmann in leder etui
rausfinden wir gehen an die bahn in
hessen halten doch alles von alibaba ich
bin schon sagen es auf der hochwertigen
seite es ist ein sehr massiver flachmann
frisch und lecker equipment was steht
denn hier
[Musik]
ich schreibe erst mal an der seite 20
euro auf ich meine es kann ja auch sein
dass der 30 euro kostet 20 euro es
erstmal so ein wert es ist wirklich
schön ich mich nicht falsch versteht ich
möchte natürlich aus tiefsten herzen
jedes jahr eine neue chance geben
deswegen will das was ich habe es im
gefühl für
macadamia zum dritten mal zwei euro 15
jetzt kriegen denn fällt jetzt geschenk
widernatürlichen immer 14
ich dachte da sind spielkarten drin
sauer sauer harte nuss noch kleinere
moonshine flaschen ich glaube die haben
gar nicht so viele geschmacksrichtungen
deswegen wo ist einfach nur schön sauer
drin ich weiß nicht was sauer für eine
geschmacksrichtung ist aber wir werden
sie jetzt herausfinden cheers
saurer apfel definitiv behrensen saurer
apfel das schmecke ich hier raus
[Musik]
mein gott wenn 50 milliliter 215 kosten
die müssen das ja auch extra verpacken
jetzt muss ich wieder meine fantasie
anregen das sind 20 milliliter flasche
macht 80 runden einfach auf und sagen da
sind
150 gb dafür wir sind nachher
[Musik]
sofort vergessen zu sagen dieses videos
nicht gesponsert falls es noch nicht
gemerkt habt dieses videos nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle zusammen
dieses videos nicht gefallen sagt ich
dachte im politisch
nummer 15 welcher geschmack ich sage es
ist toll wie bratapfel bis 2015 in die
gasse
16vor man sieht wir jeden tag an auch
diese flaschen rein nein ist er nicht so
viele sind nur 50 milliliter betroffen
hier haben wir top
und zwar fünfter noch die lifte
nummer
17 nummer 17 ist groß
falls wir noch nicht genug kleine harte
nuss hatten und milli harte nuss hatten
kriegen wir jetzt hier noch einmal big
harte nuss 3 150 milliliter das kostest
du willst sind 91
15 99 nahe gutes made in berlin darf man
nicht vergessen nummer 18 und ich
sage noch mal
wow da ist will de vere schmeckt sehr
lecker schmeckt wie likör halt ja und
dann wäre ich werde diese gläser ja
total weil die kann man einfach wieder
verwenden für sesam körner höher salz
pfeffer irgendwas muss man reinmachen
möchte weil die sehen auch einfach
schick aus als nicht wie die sticker
abgehen aber sogar ein messbecher drauf
also was nicht verloren 18 also 19 uhr
können sie mal
das ist eine handgemachte kerze aus
einem mund ein glas entkräftet wiegeln
dem flachmann hatten wir jetzt kein
hersteller hier haben wir den hersteller
super
bricht für wendel ich aber coole idee ja
aus dem leeren gläsern kann man auch
kerzen machen der hersteller
so richtig
gesagt werden dass wir diese kerzen die
man an gräber park wer hat diese kerze
hergestellt die candle factory eine
sonder produktion für und die kerzen
werden aus nachhaltig angebautem stehen
hergestellt
dann haben sie bestimmt an diese candy
factory ihre gläser hingeschickt und
dann haben sie da ihre gläser wein
gemacht und den sticker braucht playback
ihr bitte ja bedruckte dort kerzen den
dickeren schraubglas zu verpacken von
eur wir sind irgendwie super es gibt
nicht so viel zu probieren wir sind so
schnell durch geräusche gerüche nummer
jetzt ist tobi drin schon wieder harte
nuss einmal hatten immer einen 20
es heißt kunstleder gläser untersätze
aus leder oder kunstleder ich bin da
sehr unsicher ich kenne mich damit nicht
so aus sind stylisch passen für das
produkt habe nichts auszusetzen was
kosten die drei euro das war jetzt 21
22 ich dachte sind schon durch mit dem
flächen ich sage da ist drin trophy
wilde beeren haben einfach kein glück
beim raten heute da komm ich probier mal
den wilde werte nochmals freitag leute
braucht die hände wochenende
wer war gut gemeint
also ich hab das gefühl man muss die auf
jeden fall mit irgendwas mixen oder
zumindestens kalt trinken aber so cool
finde ich also irgendwie zum nächsten
beziehungsweise hermann kann die
wahrscheinlich auch wenn sie kalt
sondern schmecken sie wahrscheinlich
auch kein guthaben so angst etwas
falsches zu sagen zu böse rüberzukommen
dass ich die ganze zeit merke dass ich
so naja gut aber wir packen wir erstmal
zu ende aus tschechien nummer 22 hat mir
gerade natürlich enorme wut
also die werbegeschenke dir also sind ja
hier viele werbegeschenke sind aber also
ich finde die werbegeschenke sind alle
sehr stilvoll es ist jetzt nicht so wie
von mir willst dass es so sinnlos war
wie solche pins und roseby projekt
sondern halt ja so relativ hochwertig
produzierte sachen schreibt für die
trotzdem als zwei euro auf kann sich
gleich denn die körper schlüpfen
wirklich wirklich weihnachten ok den
sonder geschenken waren sie bis jetzt ja
sehr gut am start deswegen bin ich sehr
gespannt was wir uns jetzt am 24 am
heilig abend schenken auch was ich auch
prüfen den flaschen eignen sich super
mann an weihnachten dann den tisch da
könnte man so als schnäppchen so dass an
jedem platz hinstellen kleine idee von
mir so etwas heiliger abend wir gehen an
unseren adventskalender und gekommen
hgm die version vom und schein
in der xxl 700 milliliter das ist eine
richtige flasche in welcher vielleicht
ein bisschen kleiner autos ist aber wie
halt eine flasche ist die frage jedem pc
in black sieht aus von der farbe wie
wild berry besteht kein geschmack kommen
leute da sag ich nicht mit plumpen
geweckt den funken
das ist kein
als ob jägermeister und so ein baby
gemacht haben so schmeckt es ist super
cool also wenn es nicht viel aufwand
jetzt so ein label zu drücken aber es
ist echt ne nette idee so mit dem emp
jack rust was kommt
entschuldigung was kostet so eine große
flasche nun scheint in 100 milliliter
kosten 24 euro 90 etwa 25 euro dotiert
die preise rechnen wir mal zusammen
zwölf mal zwei euro und 15 ist gleich 25
euro gekommen die extra war ohne den
zehn euro emp gutschein liegen wir bei
109 euro und 10 10 plus 10 euro für den
emp gutschein liegen wir bei 119 euro
das ist ja der absolute war
wie kann das denn sein
entweder
muss ja ich meine ich habe viele preise
geschätzt oder ungefähr geraten wie viel
man dafür bezahlen aber man bekommt das
für sein preis man muss halt wirklich
für diesen adventskalender muss man
wunsch ein fan sein aber warum würde man
sonst einen nun schon ab ins gelände
kaufen gern ich verkünde hiermit
feierlich emp
ok gemacht okay es ist okay und an den
schein ja also was soll man hier sagen
das sind hier so die extra sagen ich hab
noch die socken an es gab noch prall ihn
am anfang es gibt halt sehr sehr viele
schnäppchen aber es ist ja nun scheinen
adventskalender also will man nun
scheinbares stimmt um den geschmack von
sonder imp schnaps gefällt mir jetzt
nicht ganz so gut da war ich kann nichts
anderes sagen wann bekommt jetzt hier
kein super und ob extra aber man muss ja
noch die verpackung dazurechnen und die
produktion dieser ganz extra kleinen
flaschen und so und hier nicht es muss
ja alles auch der wert des kalenders ist
ungefähr 119 euro es könnte sogar sein
dass ein flachmann ich noch teurer ist
kranke moonshine
nun scheint ihr habt wieder rausgeholt
oder irgendwie ihr habt euch nochmal
richtig zusammengerauft und hat gesagt
dieses jahr regen wir für dieses ja ich
bin sehr gespannt auf eure nächsten
adventskalender hat diesen weg weiter
ich bin sehr stolz auf euch auch wenn
euch meine meinung wahrscheinlich nicht
so interessieren aber vielleicht können
wir das kapitel hinter uns lassen das
wäre doch toll für uns allen außer für
die zuschauer ihr hättet euch jetzt
natürlich bestimmt gewünscht gewünscht
dass ich nicht auf rege aber außer dass
ich jetzt 100 kleine flächen habe gibt
es nichts aufzuregen tolle sachen den
flachmann den verschenke ich dieses jahr
auf jeden fall an weihnachten oder ich
packe sie selbst wenn wir in die kirche
gehen an weihnachten menke das machen
wenn keiner hinschaut durch den so aus
es gibt ihn so timo dann können wir so
in der kirche die muss man mal ich hoffe
du guckst du das video nicht weil wir
feiern mit ihm und eltern weihnachten
deswegen
das meint das mache ich natürlich nichts
war ein schwert ermittelt man diese
schöne kerze an
ach ja ich war lose adventskalender auf
instagram noch hat man davon nicht viel
mitbekommen jetzt außer der afg
adventskalender aber ich habe so viel
adventskalender die ich wahrscheinlich
nicht mal auspacken werde nicht per
losen und und ich werde eigene
adventskalender verpacken diese eignet
sich zum beispiel auch perfekt dafür um
ihn noch mal zu verpacken und an euch
rauszuschicken und da werde ich
wahrscheinlich auch ein paar von den
hier einpacken natürlich in einem ab 18
kalender mit zum beispiel den ice de
inhalt und so freudig darauf folgt mir
instagram damit ihr den start nicht
verpasst das wird eine ganz kurze phase
seines pakets gerade alle bands kalender
schnell auf und dann werden wir sie auf
instagram packen ist kann sogar sein
dass dieses video nach den verlosung
kommen wenn das so ist dann tut es mir
jetzt leid auf jeden fall wenn es nicht
so sagt das kommt ganz schnell weil wir
müssen das ganz schnell stimme dass noch
am ersten dezember bei euch zu hause
landen und jetzt mache ich feierabend
für heute was haben wir eine stunde ein
aktives video bis zum nächsten mal und
danke wunsch ein dass ich mir jetzt
einen netten abend mache ein bisschen
wild berry
[Musik]